[Musica]
ciao a tutti
sono un artigiano lavoro in un gruppo a
rimini lavoreremo rimini e costruiamo la
motocicletta più innovativa e
tecnologica che esiste sul mercato la
costruiamo con pendente che non vogliamo
un po antiche perché siamo nati giani
che lavorano con le tecnologie di una
volta però abbiniamo queste tecnologie
montanti che una tutta la tecnologia
disponibile con gli strumenti di oggi
però non sono qui per fare una
televendita
sono qui perché in qualche maniera
io ho realizzato un sogno e vorrei
aiutare tutti i giovani a realizzare i
loro sogni perché come abbiamo visto
dalle parole dei miei predecessori e poi
il tema predominante che riguarda i
giornali di oggi vorrei parlare di
quello che sono tre elementi
fondamentali che hanno caratterizzato la
mia attività e 33 cose 3 tocchetti che
mi hanno permesso di riuscire a fare in
qualche cosa che io sappiamo
queste questi tre questi tre aspetti
della mia vita professionale sono
sognare studiare e mettere in pratica e
vorrei dire il coraggio di sognare
l'avidità di studiare e soprattutto la
capacità di mettere in pratica che sono
tre elementi che io ritengo che se
riusciamo a capire come funzionano e
come sono collegate fra di loro ci
permettono di realizzare qualunque cosa
ovviamente non essendo un un esperto in
materia didattica di esprimo il mio
sentimento dal punto di vista di quello
che è la mia esperienza quindi ti
racconterò degli aneddoti che vi
serviranno per farvi capire che sognare
studiare e mettere in pratica sono delle
cose in realtà quanto semplici e
fondamentale la motivazione e la
passione
però nel cammino per la data alla vostra
attività professionale voi vi
scontrerete con delle realtà che
rispetto a quello che normalmente le
persone ci dicono ma devi tener duro
devi far presto devi fare quest'altro
però noi siamo abituati a dirla in
pratica cosa devo fare
quando parliamo di sognare io non parlo
per sogno ha inteso come la visione
notturna è una materia che mi riguarda
quando fanno parlo di sognare io parlo
di fantasticare e immaginare
al di là della immaginazione tutto
quello che vi potrebbe accadere di più
bello che io desidero questo modo di
sognare e ovviamente perseverare nel
cercare di ottenere è di arrivare a quel
traguardo che sia
figurati vi racconto una storia quando
quando abbiamo cominciato a costruire la
prima moto
siccome l'idea era quella di fare
comunque un veicolo che a darsi sul
mercato omologare che fosse veicoli
utilizzabile da chiunque volesse
comprare a ciarlare in giro per strada
ci siamo rivolti per poter fare questi
veicoli a una grande azienda un
industria motociclistica la ducati e
abbiamo interpellato un personaggio
importante e abbiamo chiesto noi avrebbe
questo progetto siamo interessati
vorrebbe fare cinque moto ci potete dare
i motori e la risposta fu la ducati è
una grande azienda non ha tempo da
perdere con queste cose
ovviamente io siamo pestone e quindi non
mi sono accontentato di questa risposta
sono riuscito grazie a degli amici
influenti a ottenere un appuntamento con
il grande carlo supremo allora c'erano
di biagio e minori presidente
amministratore con le regalarmi ducati e
ottenere un appuntamento
avevo i capelli lunghi fino al 3 periodo
andare a tagliarmi i capelli comprare il
vestito della domenica presi un mercedes
5.000 in affitto hanno perso e sono
entrati ducati parcheggiato il
parcheggio presidenziale e sono andato a
questa riunione con questi due
personaggi che ascoltandomi capivano che
avevano a che fare con un ragazzo che
aveva tanta passione voglia di fare però
ovviamente essendo tu cartina industria
di una certa entità non potevano
accontentare la richiesta di un giovane
in questa maniera perché ci sono
comporta anche una scelta di questo tipo
comporta anche un certo tipo di rischi
di problematiche tecniche legali
amministrative dissero va bene rodorigo
le faremo sapere
un po come la menano tipo audizioni per
gli artisti no tornati a casa con mia
meraviglia
ricevetti una chiamata dicendo stanno
venendo due ingegneri a fare una
supervisione
se sei in grado di fare perché ci
dobbiamo accertare che non siate dei
cantinari che fanno dei quali questi due
personaggi rimasero bottega due giorni e
analizzeranno tutti i disegni analizzare
i processi costruttivi ci fecero un
sacco di complimenti tornarono a casa e
mi arrivò una richiesta ufficiale di
presentarmi all'ufficio commerciale dal
dottor ruggeri per andarmi a comprare e
fa un contratto per acquistare i motori
che servivano per la nostra produzione
fu una cosa straordinaria tuttora noi
siamo gli unici a bere un po tranno con
ducati e questa cosa qui ovviamente per
noi è stato l'inizio di un'avventura che
ci ha dato modo noi siamo arrivati a 200
veicoli pensavamo di parti 5
abbiamo questo
veicoli in questi anni è la cosa che da
dire ovviamente quando parli di honda
archi di un un'industria che produce 7
milioni di veicoli
noi costruiamo sono 200 veicoli ma li
facciamo tutti amano e facciamo un
prodotto che fatto proprio cucito su
misura per ogni singolo cliente
quindi abbiamo una schiera di clienti
che non è che comprano una moto visitano
la bottega che sposa una filosofia
quindi in qualche maniera la volta
quello che vorrei trasmettere ai giovani
e vero ci sono un sacco di porte che si
chiudono e abusato di no e vero è
inutile regali tanto l'esperienza di
chiunque lo dimostra ma se veramente
volete qualche cosa che siete veramente
autodeterminati non guardate in faccia
niente a nessuno ma tante dritti e
perseverate spingete sempre quella
direzione
vedrete che riuscirete
a ottenere quello che volete
questo ovviamente è inteso non solo se
qualcuno volesse fare un azienda che
costruisce molto ma questo riguarda
qualunque area del mondo del lavoro
ed ecco che entriamo nel secondo punto
lo studiare studiare
io ho la terza media sono responsabili
di progetto della moto più più
tecnologica al mondo
però ho la terza media cosa voglio dire
per questo lo studiare sentivo una
professoressa può coprire un po pochi
minuti fa che parlava di questi giovani
che dicono ma cosa me ne faccio di
quello che stiamo apprendendo pil al di
là di quello che l'anima dello studio
intesa come insegnamento distruzione
l'istruzione un'attività che viene fatta
dentro a biglietti con dei professori
che svolgono un programma e come
giustamente diceva la professione è
stata si mira a passare negli esami
ma lo studio ragazzi non è questo
lo studio è comprendere ciò che si fa
perché quella lotta quanto sono venuti i
genieri quello che ha saltato la nostra
nostro sogno è stata la competenza noi
in italia abbiamo delle abilità che sono
uniche al mondo a parte che viviamo nel
paese più bello del mondo in assoluto
[Musica]
abbiamo abbiamo veramente tutto c'è lui
solo
pensate al reno nato costruiva
elicotteri dirigeva uno scultore un uomo
solo centinaia di anni fa quando si
parla di essere in crisi bisogna parlare
di quello che venire ambiente siamo qui
siamo un popolo di fenomeni e nonostante
tutto abbiamo un potenziale illimitato
ma lo studio lo studio per ottenere la
comprensione della vita e la competenza
dei nostri
è fondamentale quando io parlo di studio
non parlano solo di prendere un volume
parlato stamattina con un amico
i pochi è un test diversità hryo che io
ho dovuto prendere la mano e andare a
ripetizione dalla professoressa di
matematica per riparare a far certi
calcoli ma posso scoperto quanti di voi
conoscono il significato della tavola
matematica eppure siete tutti i giovani
siete forse andati a scuola vent'anni ma
nessuno sa cosa l'ultima parola
matematica
adesso io dico se io ti dico che la
parola matematica significa scienza che
mette in relazione i numeri
l'aritmetica con figure serie di
geometria e analitica e gia uno dice ma
ha solo un matematico è sufficiente
tremonte un dizionario e la mola volontà
di andarsi a cercare il significato
delle parole per poter leggere e
comprendere
qualunque argomento e già questo nei
mesi tutti nelle istituzioni come
istruzione
[Applauso]
pregato il tempo appena finito come
cazzo si farà
[Applauso]
accorciamo tutto il più possibile però
quello che io mi raccomando quando si
parla di studio significa che se tu se
tu non hai mai visto un albero ed è di
scrivere qualche cosa per quelli che
verranno dopo di te e devi descrivere in
maniera analitica scientifica cos'è un
albero che cosa puoi fare
non abbiamo dati di seconda mano
iscriviti per poter comprendere cos'è un
albero e dobbiamo insegnare agli altri
o dobbiamo noi lavorare su un albero
dobbiamo stare di tutta la vita
dell'anno guardare a elencare tutte le
azioni che l'albero fa perché l'acqua
che fa una serie di lezioni quando io
dico studio dico osservare per imparare
la chiave di lo studio è una cosa
meravigliosa ragazza meravigliosa
noi abbiamo una quantità di cose che non
ci passa tutta la vita per poter
imparare e se sapessimo quanto sono
belle
sarebbe veramente veramente
incredibile poterne apprendere il più
possibile oggi voi tutti dicono
telefonino patiti degli strumenti che mi
permettono in cinque minuti di vedere
cose che io quando era un ragazzino per
me comprare un libro o comprare una
scatola di pistoni dovevo fare intendere
sun ufficio postale e passavano tre mesi
prima che riusciva bene i miei pistoni
per andare in pista come oggi voi il
ventilatore potete avere cadute cosa
questo è fantastico
ecco perché secondo me siete voi i
giovani di adesso che veramente potrebbe
fare qualche cosa per il nostro futuro
soprattutto a noi qui in italia e qui
arriviamo al terzo punto mettere in
pratica se io studio la matematica
qualunque problema vi imponete sono in
grado di risolverlo potrebbe anche
sbagliare
lo scopo dello studio è quello di
comprendere e di imparare e in questo
c'è l'essenza della vita
noi osserviamo i nostri figli e
impariamo essere genitori osservando i
nostri figli cercando di fare del nostro
meglio
[Musica]
lo studio è osservare i nostri figli per
cercare di dargli il massimo
voi siete giovani figli non ne avete o
qualcuno ora dei figli però questo è un
dato che potete applicare la vita non
solo al nostro mestiere ma è
fondamentale se voi passate un'intera
vita dentro un'aula di un istituto a
prendere qualche cosa che poi non
metterete in pratica non ha un senso
e vero il difficile scegliere la strada
giusta
ecco perché dovete tornare archivi dirlo
e sognare che cazzo te ne frega
sognate quando uno qualunque cosa volete
fare la cosa che più vi piace in
assoluto e svegliatevi al mattino e
uscite di casa e andate a fare quello
che avete sognato
se prendete ingegneria edile
come minimo mi aspetto da voi che fate
dei punti che sia nomi intanto
bellissimi ma soprattutto che non
trovino in qualunque area voi andrete ad
applicare la vostra attività
se voi avete costruito un edificio come
questo si vede che qui c'è qualcuno che
ha usato il cervello qualcuno che ha
messo in pratica delle idee intelligenti
e qualcuno che in origine ha sognato di
fare un posto del genere così tutte le
cose della vita
voi giovani con questo vantaggio che
avete nella vostra era non fatevi
sfuggire l'occasione
non dimenticatevi di chi sia oggi fanno
tutti della cina del dopoguerra
noi in italia eravamo i veri cinesi
lavoravamo giorno e notte tutti i nostri
genitori
tutti lavorano giorno e notte facevano
un prodotto di altissima qualità
oggi in tutto il mondo si parla del made
in italy perché perché si faceva un
lavoro di altissimo di me
e lo si faceva nel migliore dei modi con
la 3 attività che sono noi amiamo
cosa volete di più
osservate quello che è la nostra storia
e con gli strumenti che avete studiate
come fare per il nostro futuro
io mi auguro che mi dispiace ci sono
andato fuori tempo capo ti chiede scusa
però mi auguro che queste parole che io
mi ha trasmesso ci sia una scintilla che
in qualche maniera
vi faccia capire che avete un potere
illimitato
si tratta solo di mettere insieme gli
strumenti giusti e di fare le cose
giuste non si fermerà nessuno
grazie